[Music]
on this thursday night the fbi foiled a
plot to kidnap michigan's governor
i never could have imagined anything
like this the 13 militia group members
charged
the elaborate plans they allegedly made
and how president trump
is accused of being complicit stand back
and stand by he told them
another potential disaster canada's
long-term care homes aren't ready for a
second wave of kobit 19.
powering up the production of electric
vehicles the government investment
in a made-in-canada solution and
defending the earth
we have to have a decade of of change
the prize from a prince to save the
[Music]
planet
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are going to get to the spread of
covid19 here in canada in a moment in
particular the outbreaks in long-term
care homes but we
begin with stunning allegations about a
plot to overthrow
the state government in michigan to
kidnap the governor
attack the police and attempt to ignite
a civil war
in the u.s 13 men have been charged
the fbi alleges they had been planning
for months and intended to execute the
attack before the november presidential
election
the fbi quotes one of the accused saying
michigan governor gretchen whitmer
has no checks and balances at all she
has uncontrolled power right now
all good things must come to an end
today
whitmer accused president trump of
stoking their anger
when our leaders speak their words
matter
they carry weight when our leaders
meet with encourage or fraternize with
domestic terrorists they legitimize
their actions
and they are complicit anger has been
simmering for months in april gun-toting
militiamen crowded into michigan state
legislature angry about coronavirus
restrictions
and just this week the department of
homeland security warned domestic
terrorism and violent white supremacy
is the most persistent and lethal threat
to the u.s
today michigan state police had a
message for militia groups
we took an oath to protect and defend
and to serve and together we will take
swift action
against anyone who is planning or
seeking to commit
violence or harm to anyone in the state
of michigan
the alleged plot was elaborate and
chilling
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
hatred bigotry and violence have no
place
in the great state of michigan michigan
governor gretchen whitmer has been in
the center of very public political
unrest
the shocking scene of gun-wielding
protesters entering the michigan state
capitol
in april over covet 19 lockdowns but
more
shocking was something not happening in
public says the fbi
a plot to kidnap possibly kill the
michigan governor
before next month's u.s election six men
have been charged with plotting with a
militia group
to kidnap whitmer and overthrow the
government the alleged conspirators are
extremists
who undertook a plot to kidnap a sitting
governor because of the hard work of the
men and women of law enforcement
police officers and federal agents
violence has been prevented today
the federal affidavit says there were
undercover agents and informants and
recordings made
it says some in the group engaged in
tactical training and building
explosives
one plan kidnapped the governor at her
personal vacation home
one accused adam fox described a
snatch-and-grab man
grab the effing governor just grab her
the plan then to remove the governor to
a secure location in wisconsin
for some kind of trial among the accused
is brendan caserta
who the detroit news has identified as
the man featured in a number of online
video rants on tick tock
the price of freedom is eternal
vigilance
seven others also face state charges
bringing to 13 in all the number
arrested i'll be honest i never could
have imagined anything like this
whitmer praised the police but the
democratic governor then turned to the
u.s
president donald trump tweeted earlier
this year liberate michigan
in the recent presidential debate he
suggested one right-wing group to stand
by
hate groups heard the president's words
not as a rebuke
but as a rallying cry this expert on
counterterrorism suggests
right-wing groups believe they have
trump on their side and some
could resort to violence a lot of us
have been worried about the atmosphere
in the united states leading up to the
election in november
and the fact that there are hundreds
hundreds of right-wing groups
that are against a whole bunch of things
u.s homeland security said this week
that white supremacist extremists will
remain the most persistent and lethal
threat in the homeland
and many americans are concerned with
president trump's troubled re-election
bid
now in the home stretch eric sorensen
global news
let's go to our washington bureau chief
jackson perasco jackson this is chilling
stuff you might expect to hear something
from the american president after the
fbi
foil a plot to kidnap a governor has
there been any response from the white
house well donna i can tell you the
white house press secretary has gone on
record as accusing governor whitmer of
sewing division and this morning before
those charges were announced
the president did phone into fox
business channel where he called whitmer
the lock-up queen over coronavirus
restrictions
and suggested that she's effectively
keeping her citizens in prison
this really sort of comes as the
president continues this kind of dance
with the far right
and with militias think about his
reluctance to condemn white supremacists
after that first presidential debate
in which he told them to stand back and
stand by
and then think about the language trump
has used lines like liberate michigan
you also don't have to look much further
than the trump campaign itself
take a listen to this facebook post from
the president's son
about what trump supporters he says
should be doing on election day
the radical left are laying the
groundwork to steal this election from
my father
president donald trump their plan is to
add millions of fraudulent ballots that
can cancel your vote
and overturn the election we cannot let
that happen
we need every able-bodied man woman
to join army for trump's election
security operation
so there's sort of a sense that the
president is trying to play to
all sides here but donna this flirtation
with the far right is actually
potentially very damaging to the
president
because it risks scaring off the
moderate republicans who he needs
especially to overcome his current
deficit in the polls
jackson there's been a lot of back and
forth over a second presidential
debate now that president trump has been
infected with covid19
what's the latest is it going to happen
much like his flirtation with the far
right the coronavirus is the one thing
the president doesn't want to talk about
and so when the presidential debate
commission proposed making the next
debate a virtual format because of the
virus the president
backed out and then we had this sort of
day-long back and forth with him and joe
biden both proposing
all sorts of different ways to carry on
with further debates
the long story cut short is that it's
not
certain we will see any further debates
donna and that is potentially very risky
for president trump here
because he really needs something to
turn around his campaign at this point
without a debate he doesn't have a
chance for sort of a breakout moment in
the home stretch of this campaign
uh jackson there's been a lot of back
and forth over a second presidential
debate now that president trump has been
infected with covid19
what's the latest is it going to happen
much like his flirtation with the far
right the coronavirus is the one thing
the president doesn't want to talk about
and so when the presidential debate
commission proposed making the next
debate a virtual format because of the
virus the president backed out
and then we had this sort of day-long
back and forth with him and joe biden
both proposing all sorts of different
ways to carry on
with further debates the long story cut
short is that it's not certain we will
see any further debates donna
and that is potentially very risky for
president trump here
because he really needs something to
turn around his campaign at this point
without a debate he doesn't have a
chance for sort of a breakout moment
in the home stretch of this campaign
okay jackson prosco in washington thanks
prime minister justin trudeau was asked
today about the u.s election and said
he's hoping for a smooth transition or
clear result but is preparing in case
that doesn't happen what happens in the
united states
uh is going to be impacting canada we
are certainly all
uh hoping uh for a smooth transition or
a
a clear result if it is less clear there
may be some disruptions and
we need to be ready for any outcomes
the prime minister said he would not
comment on specifics of the us
electoral process one of the world's
leading medical journals which has never
supported or condemned an american
political candidate has published a
piece headlined
dying in a leadership vacuum the 34
editors of the new england journal of
medicine don't name
president trump but say the pandemic has
been a test of leadership and u.s
leaders have failed
they have taken a crisis and turned it
into a tragedy
the editors say when it comes to the
response to the largest public health
crisis of our time
our current political leaders have
demonstrated that they are dangerously
incompetent we should not abet them and
enable the deaths of thousands more
americans
by allowing them to keep their jobs the
u.s has the most confirmed cases and the
most deaths from covet 19
in the world more than 212 thousand
americans
have died well the wait is finally over
for thousands of canadians separated
from loved ones who live overseas
cross-border travel restrictions were
lifted today for a range of family
members
they include romantic partners of at
least a year siblings
grandparents grandchildren and those
seeking entry to canada on compassionate
grounds
people must apply for and be granted
travel authorization before coming to
canada
ottawa has not released an estimated
timeline for those approvals
there are signs a second wave of kovid
19 is beginning to hit long-term care
homes in parts of this country
despite the promises to protect the most
vulnerable and improve conditions and
staffing levels in care homes
it seems not enough has been done as of
yesterday in quebec there were active
cases in 79 private seniors homes and
long-term care facilities
ontario is now reporting active
outbreaks in 57
facilities and ontario's patient
ombudsman is warning
more must be done to avoid another
long-term care catastrophe
in a new report that documents hundreds
of complaints the ombudsman says
patients and their families were
essentially
set adrift when the pandemic hit in the
spring as ross lord reports there are
fears some facilities
are headed down that same disastrous
path now
with dozens of long-term care homes in
ontario reporting covert 19 outbreaks in
recent weeks
many in the health care system suggest
conditions are about the same as they
were
in the spring my fears are that you know
we haven't learned any lessons and we're
going to see
another wildfire spread of the pandemic
that
residents and workers are going to lose
their lives at a greater
rate than what we saw in the first
pandemic the province's long-term care
association
says some new measures are in place to
control the virus like more cleaning
we've reduced uh staff to only working
in one
one health care site and we've reduced
occupancy
admissions into these three and four
bedrooms uh
and readmissions into those rooms so
starting to
certainly ensure that there are no more
than two people in a room duncan says
staff and residents still need faster
test results
and better personal protective equipment
in a new report
ontario's patient ombudsman recommends
visits by a limited number of essential
caregivers
dedicated resources for communication
among patients or residents
families and staff enhanced
whistleblower protection
and contingency plans for all health
care providers
including a staffing plan for covet-19
outbreaks
but plan a is getting more staff to
replace front-line workers who left
their jobs
we believe that we still have thousands
of people at home
fears of a devastating second wave are
spreading across canada
even inside the so-called atlantic
bubble new brunswick had very few
coveted 19 cases
until an outbreak this week at a
long-term care home in moncton
anne-marie johnson is afraid her mother
hugette will contract the virus
i don't want to lose her that my whole
family doesn't want to lose her we lost
our dad going on two years in january
and
she's the heart of our family back in
ontario there are doubts a temporary pay
raise of three dollars an hour for
personal support workers
will make any difference their union
says only
offering more full-time jobs with
benefits will bring workers back
and attract others so homes have better
odds of suppressing the virus
ross lord global news halifax
and key to keeping vulnerable canadians
safe is getting community outbreaks
under control
that's not happening right now in parts
of quebec and ontario
quebec has moved more areas into the red
zone that's its highest alert level
and police checkpoints are being set up
to crack down on non-essential travel
for this long weekend quebecers are
asked to be
very very careful together we can break
this wave
more than a thousand people tested
positive today in quebec and in ontario
there was a record daily spike nearly
800 new infections there there were 67
new cases reported in manitoba today
18 in saskatchewan 110 new cases were
reported in bc and alberta reported its
biggest
single day increase today 364 new
infections
274 of those are in edmonton people in
that city are now being urged to limit
gatherings to 15 people
and to wear masks at indoor workplaces
i'm very concerned about the sharp rise
in cases that we are seeing
over the past week the positivity rate
has increased to four percent
in edmonton the edmonton zone now faces
a crucial
juncture while the system is able to
support the current caseload in
hospitals and icus
the acute care impact is a lagging
indicator
canada's privacy commissioner says the
pandemic has accelerated the need for
better laws on privacy and data use in
this country
daniel tyrion tabled his annual report
in parliament today he says
most interactions online from working
remotely to socializing logging into
school or
discussing health issues with a doctor
use commercial
video conferencing technology and he
says there's a risk third parties could
capture
sensitive information i'm frustrated
for canadian citizens firstly
so canadian citizens have less privacy
protection
than citizens of about 40 countries that
there's no reason why
the federal covet alert app though has
been praised for its privacy measures
but tyrion says there must be ongoing
monitoring to ensure third parties don't
get access to it
and push users to disclose information
the new jolt ii making more electric
vehicles in canada
coming up the cash injection to fuel a
greener future
the federal and ontario governments are
teaming up to provide the ford motor
company with a combined
590 million dollars to produce electric
vehicles
in oakville ontario as our chief
political correspondent david aiken
explains premier doug ford and prime
minister justin trudeau aren't political
allies
but they do seem to be kindred spirits
in some ways these days
the cars of the future zero emission
electric vehicles
and ford motor company wants to build
them to do that ford will get some
financial help
295 million dollars each from the
governments of canada and ontario
the car maker will then kick in 1.4
billion dollars of its own
to start producing electric vehicles by
2024
this will support and protect our auto
sector's
maiden ontario advantage and it will
help support good paying jobs
for ontario families and workers for
years to come
but also good jobs elsewhere these cars
for example will need aluminum from
bc and quebec this investment will make
a huge impact
throughout the supply chain including
the many
many auto parts suppliers throughout the
regions
this federal investment is part of the
trudeau liberals plan for a so-called
green recovery by investing in
technology that protects the environment
we're also taking action on our plan to
get to net
zero carbon emissions by 2050. and it's
the latest example of two former rivals
a
liberal prime minister and a
conservative premier
finding ways to work together i think
it's also deeply reassuring
to know that in this time where there is
so much uncertainty
people can have confidence in their
institutions to focus
on them and not focus on fighting each
other finally today's deal is one of the
most tangible signs that
the electric vehicle is moving into the
mainstream
in fact ford says that within a decade
electric vehicles like this one
are going to outsell the good old gas
guzzler donna
okay david aiken thank you
canada criticized still ahead
accusations of a link to a violent
regional dispute
the turkish government is accusing
canada of double standards after ottawa
suspended the export of some military
technology to turkey
there are allegations canadian-made
equipment is being used by the
turkish-backed military in azerbaijan
it's in a deadly conflict with armenia
over the disputed region of
nagorno-karabakh
as redmond shannon explains both sides
are ignoring international appeals
for a ceasefire
after 26 years of relative peace
nagorno-karabakh
is again at war this footage purportedly
shows azeri forces
attacking the region's capital on sunday
similar scenes of bombing in
azerbaijan's second city
armenia denies targeting civilians
saying it had only shelled an airbase
the nagorno-karabakh tensions have their
origins in the 1991
demise of the soviet union when armenia
and azerbaijan declared independence
the ethnically armenian region legally
remained inside
azerbaijan a war ensued followed by a
peace deal in 1994
that saw ethnic armenians control
nagorno-karabakh
with support from armenia world powers
are broadly remaining neutral
with the exception of turkey a military
ally of azerbaijan
currently flexing its muscles across the
region
on monday canada suspended the export of
some military equipment to turkey
after allegations that parts were being
sent on to azeri forces
the set of rules that we have under the
law under regulation
require the minister of foreign affairs
to look at a piece of equipment
with respect to a destination with
respect to the use of the equipment and
a hand user statement
ngo project plowshares says a drone
video released by azerbaijan
strongly resembles those taken by
sensors made by canadian company
wescam in burlington ontario wescam
declined to comment to global news
i would be astonished if global affairs
did not have an idea that turkey was
actually misusing these weapons
earlier the export suspension came after
lobbying from canada's
large armenian community turkey has
accused ottawa of a double standard
because canada continues to export arms
to saudi arabia
despite its involvement in the war in
yemen i would actually agree with with
the government of turkey and coming out
and saying
there totally is a double standard
canada's foreign minister francois
philippe champagne is meeting european
leaders
next week to push for a ceasefire
redmond shannon global news
london earth shots wanted next the royal
drive to repair our planet
you're watching global national
british broadcaster sir david
attenborough has been warning for a long
time that the earth is at a tipping
point
now he's joined forces with prince
william to launch a 5 million
competition called earth shot the idea
is to spark and reward bright ideas and
innovation to reverse the human impact
on the planet
as crystal gamansing explains people are
being told to dream big
the earthshot prize is fashioned after
john f kennedy's
moonshot time for this nation to take a
clearly
leading role in space achievement
which in many ways may hold the key to
our future on earth
prince william is looking to spur action
to benefit us
all saving earth and and really focusing
our attention on on doing
really ambitious targets on earth much
like the same way you put a man on the
moon
working with the duke of cambridge sir
david attenborough
a man dedicated to exploring and
documenting our changing world it's got
a magic to it let's hope it has a magic
touch
but that human touch has also been
detrimental
having watched so many david adams
documentaries recently with with my
children they absolutely love them
the most recent one the extinction one
actually george and i had to turn it off
we got so sad about it halfway through
and he said to me he said you know i
don't want to watch this anymore it's
why is it why does it come to this
it's a question and cause long
championed by charles the prince of
wales
we've forgotten sometimes i think that
that we are part of nature
so what we do to the world around us we
are doing totally to ourselves
the earthshot prize is focused on five
areas reviving our oceans
restoring and protecting nature fixing
our climate
clean air and building a waste-free
world
prince william and an international
council including environmentalists
celebrities business leaders
and an astronaut will decide which
projects to support
it's a team i i've said to everyone so
far that i'm
i'm the uh the very boring kind of like
coach on the corner at the moment
if we all put our forces together
for a common goal we can make a great
achievement
earthshot prize nominations open in
november
with the first set of one million pound
awards
being presented next fall crystal
gamansen global news
london
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is this
wheat field near portage prairie
manitoba which is not far from the farm
where i grew up
there are beautiful spots all over
canada please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye
[Music]